en el vídeo anterior hablamos sobre las
diversas funciones del dinero la primera
es que es un medio de intercambio si
queremos algo típicamente le damos a
esta persona que tiene ese algo dinero
para comprarlo en lugar de
intercambiarlo por algo que nosotros
tengamos e intercambiar naranjas por
manzanas o caballos por servicios
legales la segunda es que es un depósito
de valor si ahorramos dinero su valor no
se va a perder
a diferencia de si guardamos un montón
de manzanas ya que cuando pase el tiempo
y comiencen a echarse a perder pues
también van a perder su valor y la
tercera función es que es una unidad de
cuenta es una forma en la que asignamos
números a objetos para saber qué tanto
vale algo algo que vale 500 pesos va a
valer el doble de algo que vale 250
pesos y el tener este sistema de números
para el valor nos ayuda a comparar
diferentes bienes
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
hablar sobre las circunstancias en las
que estas funciones del dinero dejan de
existir y en específico vamos a hablar
del caso de la hiperinflación la
inflación quiere decir que los precios
aumentan si vemos el precio de una
botella de leche y vemos que cuesta 20
pesos un día va a aumentar su precio más
adelante quizás al día siguiente valga
25 pesos y cuando el precio de todas las
cosas en una economía tienden a aumentar
y no es el caso de que la leche esté
escasea no solamente se le llama
inflación y la hiperinflación es
básicamente que esto ocurre con mucha
rapidez en cada academia y tenemos otros
vídeos en donde hablamos sobre la
inflación y qué es lo que la ocasiona
por lo que aquí no entraremos en
detalles aquí sólo nos interesa
comprender la idea de que los precios
van a aumentar con mucha rapidez y para
ver sólo un ejemplo de los muchos que
han ocurrido en la historia
no es necesariamente el ejemplo más
impactante pero nos interesa en términos
de cómo lo solucionaron brasil en la
década de 1980 y principios de la década
de 1990 estaba viviendo una
hiperinflación y para que se den una
idea del tamaño de esta hiperinflación
su punto más alto llegó a ser de 80 por
ciento por mes lo que significa que cada
mes los precios de las cosas generales
una botella de leche o una silla o el
precio de la tierra cosas por el estilo
generalmente se multiplicaban por un
factor de 1.8 ahora si vemos esto
durante un año en el que cada mes todo
aumenta por un factor de 1.8 y esto
ocurre 12 meses tendremos que esto
aumentó a más de un factor de 1000 lo
que significa que si tenemos algo que
costó 100 pesos hoy
después de un año si la inflación
aumenta con esta tasa pues dentro de un
año valdrá 100 mil pesos por lo que la
tasa de inflación anual el porcentaje
anual es de 100 mil por ciento al año y
en la historia han habido tasas de
inflación mucho más rápidas que ésta
pero ésta sigue siendo bastante loca y
para darnos una idea de cómo sería vivir
en una economía así imaginemos una
economía super simplificada en donde
tenemos cuatro tipos diferentes de
personas y los vamos a llamar a estas
personas la persona a persona ve
personas y persona de y vamos a imaginar
que esta economía funciona de esta
manera la persona
compra todo lo que necesita de la
persona ve por lo que a le da ave no sé
digamos que 500 pesos al mes y ve le da
a todo lo que necesita ahora ve compra
todo lo que necesita veces
digamos que ella le da todo lo que tiene
que son los 500 pesos que reciben se los
da hace y a su vez se le da todo lo que
necesita a ve de manera similar se le da
todo el dinero que tienen los 500 pesos
de ida le proporciona todo lo que
necesita hacer y finalmente de compra
todas sus cosas de a por lo que le da a
el dinero que tiene 500 pesos y a cambio
recibe las cosas que necesita este es un
ejemplo de economía super simplificada
pero creo que les da la sensación de
como los ingresos de una persona se
vuelven los gastos de otra persona y
ahora imaginemos que nos encontramos en
una situación de hiperinflación y
tenemos un aumento no sé del 80 por
ciento por mes algo que cuesta 100 pesos
un mes al siguiente mes va a costar 180
pesos digamos
que nosotros somos la persona y sabemos
que va a haber un aumento en el precio
podríamos anticiparnos a esto y aumentar
nuestros precios desde antes por lo que
le podemos decir a la persona de el día
de hoy las cosas valen en lugar de 500
pesos 510 pesos pues las cosas se están
volviendo más caras cada vez y yo
necesito cobrar más lo que va a hacer es
decir chispas tengo que pagar más bueno
entonces ahora yo venderé mis cosas más
caras hace así que también le voy a
cobrar 510 pesos y a su vez se dice
chispas pues voy a tener que cobrar a mi
cliente de 510 pesos también para poder
comprar lo que yo necesito de manera que
todos tienen que aumentar sus precios
para poder adquirir lo que necesitan y
cuando llega el día siguiente ninguno
querrá ser el último en aumentar sus
precios quizás ahora me diga bueno ayer
me aumentaron los precios
que gane menos y tuve que gastar más por
lo que hoy me voy a asegurar de no ser
la última así que voy a aumentar mis
precios de una vez y dice bueno ahora
voy a cobrar a 530 pesos para asegurarme
bien y ahora and se da cuenta que
aumentaron los precios por lo que va a
tener que aumentar los precios de lo que
vende y todos tienen que hacer esto y el
ciclo continúa ya que todos para poder
comprar lo que necesitan tienen que
aumentar el precio de lo que venden y
esta circunstancia en el que las
personas aumentan con anticipación sus
precios para prevenirse de cambios
futuros es lo que caracteriza a la
hiperinflación en sentido cualitativo en
comparación con la inflación regular hay
una frase que me gusta que creo que dijo
napoleón que dice en donde la cantidad
tiene en sí misma cierta cualidad y éste
sin duda es el caso en la hiperinflación
ya que la inflación ordinaria que
digamos es de uno a tres por ciento por
año
obviamente esto es dramáticamente más
pequeño que 100.000 por ciento por año
pero la hiperinflación no es solamente
que aquí tengamos un número mucho más
grande sino la diferencia psicológica en
la sociedad en donde las personas
comienzan a anticipar los aumentos en el
precio y cambian desde antes los precios
de lo que venden y es así como esto se
sale de control es así como tenemos
números tan locos como 80% por mes y por
qué hablamos de esto si nuestro vídeo
trata de funciones del dinero bueno en
el caso de la hiperinflación si vemos
estas funciones del dinero y analizamos
si siguen aplicando o no en una economía
con hiperinflación vemos la primera el
medio de intercambio está sigue
funcionando el dinero sigue siendo el
medio de intercambio las personas siguen
comprando cosas usando la moneda local
el depósito de valor deja de funcionar
ya que si digamos nosotros tenemos 100
pesos ahorrados
y sabemos que las cosas están aumentando
su precio a 100.000 por ciento por año
pues lo que ahorramos valdrá 100 mil por
ciento menos el próximo año así que esto
ya no me sirve como depósito de valor y
ustedes podrían decir que incluso en una
inflación ordinaria esto ocurre ya que
aunque los precios estén aumentando poco
a poco de un 1 a 3 por ciento por año
sigue siendo el caso en el que el peso
que estamos ahorrando si no lo
invertimos o cobramos intereses por él
se va a ir degradando poco a poco en el
tiempo así que podríamos decir que en
una inflación normal ordinaria la
función de depósito de valor pues
tampoco se aplica muy bien
pero consideremos esta tercera función
del dinero que es la unidad de cuenta si
estamos viviendo en una economía con
hiperinflación los números de precios
que vemos ya no van a corresponder al
valor de los objetos o servicios que
tienen ya no van a corresponder al valor
de los productos o servicios que tienen
si esto tenía un valor de 500 pesos y el
siguiente año cuesta 500 mil ya no
estamos viendo el valor de este objeto
en términos de la moneda local y durante
la historia se ha dado casos en donde
las personas comienzan a comparar el
valor de las cosas usando una moneda
extranjera si el valor de la moneda
local fluctúa muy rápidamente buscaremos
una moneda un poco más estable para
calcular el valor de algo en lugar de
decir bueno cuál es el valor de una
botella de leche en lugar de pensar en
términos de la moneda local podremos
decir bueno vale un euro o alguna otra
moneda que sea un poco más estable por
lo que esta función de unidad de cuenta
ya no
sirve en una hiperinflación y esto es
algo diferente entre la inflación
ordinaria y la hiperinflación porque
digamos que aunque en cierto país la
inflación aumente poco a poco estos
países siguen pensando en el valor de
las cosas en términos de su propia
moneda local por lo que esta es una
diferencia medular entre estas dos
inflación es y distingue a la
hiperinflación de la inflación en
términos cualitativos y lo interesante
de pensar en la hiperinflación de brasil
a diferencia de otras hiperinflación es
de otros países durante la historia en
donde se han tenido hiperinflación es
aún más grandes es que hicieron algo muy
interesante para solucionarlo cualquier
solución tiene que ver cuáles son las
causas inherentes de la hiperinflación y
aquí no vamos a ver estos detalles
tienen que ver con que el gobierno sea
físicamente responsable tiene que ver
con balancear presupuestos y cosas por
el estilo pero un componente diferente
que tiene que atenderse es que el dinero
ya no sirve como unidad
por lo que algo interesante que hizo
brasil a inicios de la década de 1990 es
que introdujo una moneda falsa que se
llama usb que son las iniciales en
portugués de unidad de real valor no sé
portugués pero estas son las iniciales
rb y lo que hicieron fue decir ok bueno
todos pueden seguir pagando usando la
moneda local que me parece que en ese
entonces era el cruzeiro que seguía
sirviendo como medio de intercambio pero
lo que dijeron es que cada vez que se
ponga el precio a algo por favor no solo
pongan el precio en términos del
cruzeiro que digamos en este caso yo
escribí las cantidades en términos de
pesos pero imaginemos que son cruceros
así que además de poner el precio en
términos de cruceros también por favor
incluyan el valor del objeto en términos
de un revés que en este caso sería de
500 ya que todo comenzó en 500 y
asociaron esta moneda inventada al
dólar americano por lo que durante el
tiempo aunque aumentaba el precio en
términos de cruceros y cada quien
pagando cada vez más y más en términos
de cruceros la unidad de valor real
permanecía igual ya que no tenía una
razón de aumentar pues es un número
inventado que se asociaba a las cosas
para tener una idea de su valor así que
lo que dijeron es que bueno nuestra
moneda local no está cumpliendo con la
función de unidad de cuenta así que
inventemos algo nuevo que sí lo haga así
que en este momento el cruzeiro seguía
cumpliendo la función de medio de
intercambio y nada estaba cumpliendo la
función de depósito de valor
excepto cosas como terrenos y esta
moneda inventada servía para cubrir la
función de unidad de cuenta conforme las
personas se hacían a la idea de que si
tenían que ir a comprar leche y saben
que vale una unidad de valor real y sólo
tenían que buscar cuántos cruceros
correspondían a una url las personas
comenzaron a pensar en las cosas en
términos de este número aún cuando
pagaban en términos de otro
y ya que esto se estableció en la
psicología de la sociedad al mismo
tiempo que el gobierno aplicaba las
sanciones correspondientes para
solucionar esto hicieron el cambio para
usar la unidad real de valor como moneda
local y comenzaron a imprimir dinero en
términos de estos bebés abandonando el
cruzeiro incluso diciéndole a las
personas que podrían intercambiar los
cruceros que tuvieran por monedas en usb
que ya era la nueva moneda y esto fue
por la idea que tenían las personas de
ver a este número como un número estable
y pensaban en los precios en términos de
este número estable y ya que además
estaban solucionando las causas
subyacentes a esta hiperinflación
todo esto funcionó y este número se
mantuvo estable por lo que en lugar de
tener precios que aumentaban un 80 por
ciento al mes de incrementaron
drásticamente a algo que era mucho más
cercano a la inflación de una economía
saludable y yo creo que esto fue algo
muy poderoso
que podemos reconocer cuando una función
ya no es realizada por la moneda y
atacarla específicamente y solucionar la
específicamente inventando algo que
tenga esta función como una moneda
inventada que es una cantidad que le
asignamos a las cosas para que cumpla
esta función claro fue una moneda
inventada es solo un número que le
asignamos a las cosas pero sirvió a esta
función y se aplicó en un entorno real a
la escala de toda una nación y resolver
un problema económico y espero que esto
haya sido útil para entender cuáles son
las funciones del dinero en términos de
estas tres categorías diferentes nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo